this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description
Democrats on the House Judiciary
Committee have now decided on the
language of two articles of impeachment
against President Trump is the
president's conduct really impeachable
is this a political charade and are
Democrats stepping out of line by
drafting these two particular articles
of impeachment well to figure that out
we have to look at the only three other
times this has ever happened
let's compare president Trump's articles
of impeachment to presidents Johnson
Nixon and Clinton hey legal eagles it's
time to think like a lawyer because we
are living in very interesting times
today we're going to talk about how
impeachment works in how and when you're
allowed to throw a president out of
office
why are we talking about impeachment
right now no reason just seemed like a
fun thing to do so let's start at the
beginning where does impeachment come
from impeachment is a process that lets
Congress remove federal office holders
from their position when they do
something wrong where does this idea
come from well like most of the things
that relate to the law of our country it
comes from England impeachment was a
process the Parliament used to limit the
power of kings and queens since they
couldn't impeach the royal family
English Parliament would impeach the
king or queen's ministers and favors
basically anyone connected to the crown
who had amassed too much power and used
it in inappropriate ways if someone
abused their power neglected their
duties missed use funds encroached on
Parliament's power or betrayed the
nation's trust they could be impeached
which often meant they were thrown in
jail Parliament referred to these issues
as high crimes and misdemeanors you'll
probably recognize that phrase in the US
Constitution high crimes and
misdemeanors in English law referred to
offenses against the country itself and
not necessarily criminal offenses per se
so fast-forward to the American colonies
the American colonists were not entirely
happy with the way that King George
treated them so they started it
effectively impeaching colonial
officials who reported to the crown in
the American colonies this was a risky
play since colonial governments
technically didn't have the legal right
to impeach anyone since the colonists
didn't have the power to subject
officials to criminal penalties
like prison the penalty for impeachment
in the colonies was for the office
holder to be removed from office when
the English crown warned the American
colonists to stop the impeachment
proceedings eventually that was one of
the factors that led to the breakup with
the English monarchy entirely that's why
the Declaration of Independence is part
breakup letter part burn book and part
impeachment notice the declaration lists
grievances against King George and
insists that Americans have the right to
fire him after the Revolutionary War
eight of the original 13 colonies added
impeachment power to their state
constitutions when the Constitution was
ratified it included this important tool
found in article 2 section 4 the
president vice-president and all civil
officers of the United States shall be
removed from office on impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors so
how does impeachment work article 1
gives the House of Representatives the
power of impeachment and the Senate the
power to hold an impeachment trial the
House of Representatives acts as the
prosecutor bringing formal charges
against the federal officer or the
president while the Senate holds the
actual trial itself for impeachment and
removal of office for a person to be
convicted and removed from office
two-thirds of the Senate must vote to
convict removal from office is the only
penalty which can result from
impeachment this brings us to the most
important question of all what actions
can get a federal officer impeached
technically the answer is found right
there in article 2 section 4 a person
can be impeached for treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors the
problem is that language doesn't really
give us the guidance that we need to
figure out what specific actions are
required to remove someone from office
but the first two criteria are easy
calls if a public official commits
treason or bribery he or she is
obviously acting on behalf of another
country or for the direct interest of
themselves over the interests of the
country which makes impeachment a
relatively easy call it's generally the
other requirement for high crimes and
misdemeanors that causes all of the
vexation so what is a high crime or
misdemeanor the term isn't defined in
our law or in the Constitution so we
have to define it first by stating what
it is not the founding fathers were
concerned about offenses committed
against the country itself by people in
high places of authority therefore the
term high crime probably
mean necessarily a high felony like a
murder or kidnapping instead the phrase
probably implies a crime by a person in
the government in a high place of
authority just like it did in England
against the people who are surrogates
for the crown of England we also know
that high crime can't mean a very very
bad felony or crime because it's paired
with a misdemeanor the Constitution also
says a public official can be impeached
for a quote misdemeanor an American
criminal law a misdemeanor is a crime
punishable by less than one year in jail
misdemeanors are crimes like petty theft
possession of marijuana disorderly
conduct in public intoxication you know
all the fun things if we use the
standard legal definition of misdemeanor
in criminal law then that would expose
federal officials to removal for really
basic infractions but is that really
what the founding fathers were after
probably not contemporary writings show
that the founders probably understood
misdemeanor as a way to punish quote
malversation in office malversation is
an almost obsolete word but it basically
means corrupt behavior by a person in a
position of public trust now I can
almost feel your frustration right now
if there isn't a list of high crimes and
misdemeanors to go off of where do we
turn to next well the best resource we
have is precedent and we can examine how
impeachment has been used in the past so
let's talk about first non presidential
impeachment impeachment has only been
used 17 times against officials of lower
rank than president no one has been
impeached for treason but three people
have been impeached for bribery
including two judges and a cabinet
member the rest were considered high
crimes these cases fall into three
categories the first one is for people
who abuse the office for improper
purpose this usually means things like
taking bribes or kickbacks
the second category involves things like
exceeding the constitutional balance of
the powers of office most people who
were impeached for abuse of power have
been federal judges they're problematic
actions include things like showing bias
towards certain litigants abusing the
contempt of court powers and imprisoning
lawyers who were critical of the judges
the third category is reserved for
conduct grossly incompatible with a
proper function and purpose of the
office this includes incompetence or
moral failings that may not be a
but which Sulli the office for example a
few judges were impeached for being
drunks who ranted and raved from the
bench I've certainly never been in front
of any judges who acted like that at all
and all of the judges that I've been in
front of especially the ones that voted
for my client were upstanding citizens
now moral failings have also been
considered impeachment worthy including
groping subordinate employees this was
also done by an out-of-control federal
judge these examples don't exactly set
an extremely high bar for impeachment
from a behavioral standpoint still there
have been fewer impeachments than one
would probably assume over time that's
mostly because the decision to impeach
in an office holder is a serious one and
political considerations also play a
role this is especially the case when
Congress is debating whether to impeach
a sitting president so let's talk about
the elephant in the room
what is the presidential standard for
impeachment
well when Bill Clinton was subject to an
impeachment inquiry his lawyers argued
that the standards should be much higher
for removal of the most powerful person
in government although there may be some
logic to this argument you can also
argue that the president should be held
to a higher standard of conduct because
that person is the most powerful person
in the American government to see how
various Congress's have interpreted the
legal standard for impeachment let's
take a look at the attempted impeachment
of three u.s. presidents Andrew Johnson
Richard Nixon and Bill Clinton we'll
start with Andrew Johnson the first
president to face impeachment was Andrew
Johnson who became president after
Lincoln's assassination the Republicans
in Congress at the time strongly
disagreed with President Johnson's it's
hemp to stop newly freed former slaves
from getting equal rights Congress even
drew up articles impeachment stating
this however they got nowhere with this
particular argument and not enough
representatives would impeach on those
grounds and during the ensuing power
struggle Congress passed the tenure of
office act to try to ensnare Johnson in
a trap the law stripped the president's
right to fire executive branch officials
without the Senate's consent the law
stipulated that if Johnson violated the
Act it constituted a high misdemeanor
which Congress would consider an
impeachable offense
President Johnson eventually fired the
Secretary of War triggering the tenure
of office act the House drew up articles
of impeachment and voted overwhelmingly
to
on those grounds interestingly since
people have focused on the process
associated with president Trump's
impeachment here it took only five days
for Congress to pass the tenure of
office act and then file articles of
impeachment against President Johnson
the house brought eleven articles of
impeachment against Johnson these are
perhaps the broadest articles of
impeachment against any president in
history and given the craven political
nature of these particular articles of
impeachment probably the most
controversial as well the Johnson
articles of impeachment included
dismissing Edward Stanton from office
after the Senate had voted not to concur
with his dismissal and had ordered him
reinstated and conspiring to prevent him
from continuing appointing Lorenzo
Thomas as Secretary of War at interim
despite the lack of vacancy in the
office since the dismissal of Stanton
had been allegedly invalid and without
the advice and consent of the Senate
conspiring to unlawfully violate and
curtail faithful execution of a tenure
of office act and take possession of the
property of the department of war
issuing orders to violate federal law
requiring all military orders to be
issued through the general of the army
making three speeches with intent to
quote attempt to bring into disgrace
ridicule hatred contempt and reproach
the Congress of the United States and
finally bringing disgrace and ridicule
to the presidency by his aforementioned
words and actions but the story wasn't
over the Senate still needed to convict
thirty-five senators voted guilty and
nineteen voted not guilty thus falling
short by one single vote of the
two-thirds majority required for
conviction under the Constitution now
while this is a gross over summary
Johnson had a legitimate gripe the law
passed by Congress limiting his powers
was unconstitutional the Supreme Court
ruled it was unconstitutional in 1926
but the Republican members of the House
also had a legitimate gripe President
Johnson turned his back on Lincoln's
reconstruction plan because he had an
antipathy toward african-americans so
what can we deduce from this particular
incident well it's a mixed bag Johnson
and Congress were having a political
dispute about the future of the nation a
dispute that would dramatically impact
both ex-confederates and newly freed
slaves well you'll notice that Johnson's
impeachment wasn't about breaking a
criminal law it's important to remember
that breaking a criminal law could be
grounds
impeachment but the president doesn't
need to commit a crime in order to face
impeachment and it's hard the Johnson
impeachment was a political issue both
sides really had failed in their oath of
office both the president was refusing
to execute the laws and Congress was
passing unconstitutional laws to ensnare
the president and ultimately Johnson
fell only one vote short of the vote
needed to remove him from office which
brings us to the near impeachment of
President Richard Nixon so let's review
the basics of the Watergate scandal that
led to Richard Nixon's resignation now
this is really just going to be the
basics this is an incredibly complicated
part of American history that I'm not
going to do justice but perhaps in a
later video I'll cover it in more detail
during the summer of 1971 President
Nixon wasn't broiled in the increasingly
unpopular Vietnam War Daniel Ellsberg a
Department of Defense military analyst
started leaking government secrets about
the war to various newspapers the
biggest leak was a top-secret report now
known as the Pentagon Papers which was a
confidential history of what America had
been doing in Vietnam
President Nixon established a team of
special operatives to plug the leaks and
engage in a number of illegal but Pro
Nixon shenanigans the group gave
themselves the nickname the plumbers the
plumbers engaged in all kinds of illicit
activities including breaking into
Ellsberg psychiatrist office to steal
medical records and supporting a
Democratic candidate who Nixon felt he
could easily defeat Nixon's team also
planted bugs in the offices of the
Democratic National Committee which were
located in the Watergate office complex
they later broke into the offices a
second time to fix those recording
devices
the FBI eventually caught the Watergate
burglars and Congress launched an
investigation eventually over a
multi-year investigation the story came
out
President Nixon made secret audio tapes
of conversations in the White House he
knew about the plumbers he knew about
the Watergate burglars and he ordered
his subordinates to help cover up those
activities now although the malfeasance
goes back to at least 1971 a
congressional Select Committee wasn't
formed until February of 1973 and during
the course of the investigation into the
Nixon White House special prosecutor
Archibald Cox issued a subpoena for the
secret White House audio tapes
President Nixon refused to comply with
the subpoena and instead fired the
special prosecutor in October of 1973
which is the so called Saturday night
massacre
on March 1st 1974 a grand jury in
Washington DC indicted several former
aides of Nixon who became known as the
Watergate seven when Cox's successor
sought the tapes and Nixon refused the
case went to the Supreme Court the court
ruled in July of 1974 in a unanimous
eight to zero decision against President
Nixon's claim that the tapes were
protected by executive privilege
President Nixon was ultimately charged
with three articles of impeachment
though it's interesting that two
articles of impeachment were actually
rejected by the house the three articles
of impeachment that were adopted against
Nixon included obstruction of justice by
using his powers of office to cover-up
the Watergate break-in abuse of power by
disregarding Nixon's constitutional duty
to faithfully execute the laws of the
United States and administration of
justice and contempt of Congress by
disobeying congressional subpoenas
seeking evidence that was quote deemed
and necessary by the committee in order
to resolve by direct evidence
fundamental factual questions relating
to presidential direction knowledge or
approval of actions demonstrated by
other evidence to be substantial grounds
for impeachment of the President in
other words disregarding congressional
subpoenas about what the president knew
and when he knew it the two articles of
impeachment that were rejected against
Nixon included usurping the powers of
Congress and hiding the fact that the
u.s. had bombed Cambodia and an
emolument violation related to tax fraud
so with the house ready to vote on the
impeachment articles President Nixon
resigned before facing the actual formal
impeachment which takes us into the more
modern era the third presidential
impeachment involves President Bill
Clinton during Clinton's presidency a
special prosecutor was appointed to
investigate the so-called whitewater
affair which was not one of Bill
Clinton's extramarital affairs but
rather a failed real estate company that
the Clintons had been involved in back
in 1978 appointed special counsel
Kenneth Starr turned through evidence
about whitewater without finding any
serious offense so he expanded the
investigation to include other matters
and in this expanded investigation
Clinton's long history of extramarital
affairs and sexual harassment
allegations caught up with him an
Arkansas a woman named Paula Jones sued
Clinton for sexual harassment during the
lawsuit her legal team uncovered
information that Clinton had an affair
with a young intern while he was
president the intern
Monica Lewinsky told her friend Linda
Tripp as part of the expanded
investigation Starr investigated
President Clinton's actions to cover up
the affair and obstruct the sexual
harassment lawsuit Starr would
eventually chronicle all of this
information in a 500 page report House
Republicans on that basis decided to
impeach the articles of impeachment
against President Clinton are by far the
simplest and there are only two and
they're pretty straightforward the first
is lying to a grand jury about Monica
Lewinsky and the second is attempting to
obstruct justice regarding the civil
case by Paula Jones against President
Clinton on those articles the House
voted to impeach but the Senate voted to
acquit President Clinton ending the
impeachment so what do we make of all
this well Gerald Ford once criticized
the impeachment processes meaning quote
whatever a majority of Congress says it
is he meant the impeachment is a purely
political device and on some level
whether something is impeachable is a
tautology if you have the votes then it
is impeachable impeachment is first and
foremost a political tool and one way of
looking at the Clinton impeachment is
that while perjury and obstruction of
justice are serious and felonies the
Senate simply didn't believe that
President Clinton's perjury and
obstruction of justice violations
involved matters that gravely impacted
the public but another way of looking at
it is that it was simply a craven
political move and there's no rhyme or
reason behind it other than that so what
can we surmise from these three
different attempts to impeach presidents
well there are several key principles
first is that the founders provided a
tool that can be used for good or ill it
all depends on the circumstances the
second is that there is a legal standard
that is not purely political the
standard for impeaching the president is
broad enough to encompass things like
treason bribery crimes corruption and
moral failings but the Senate doesn't
necessarily need to find the president
guilty of a criminal offense for the
president to be impeached and third
political factors absolutely do play a
role in impeachment proceedings Congress
decides whether a president should be
impeached and their decisions are often
rooted in practical political
considerations rather than legal ones so
what is going to happen with President
Trump and how will history look back on
this well impeachment is back in the
news because the
rats appear to be moving forward with
formal impeachment inquiries article 1
is labeled abuse of power in that
article the house alleges the president
Trump abused the power of the presidency
by using the power of his office to
solicit a foreign government to
interfere in the 2020 presidential
election in his favor and for his own
personal gain as Donald Trump the
individual he conditioned official acts
of the United States government on
receiving personal gain and subverting
the national interest of the United
States and corrupted the democratic
election that will take place in 2020
the second article of impeachment is
labeled obstruction of Congress there
the house alleges that the president
obstructed Congress's lawful impeachment
inquiry by directing the executive
branch agencies offices and officials
not to comply with congressional
subpoenas regarding the impeachment
inquiry effectively the executive branch
led by President Trump has completely
stonewalled the entire congressional
impeachment efforts and of course
Congress has sole impeachment authority
now you can disagree about the merits
but it appears that these articles of
impeachment against President Trump are
grounded solidly in the foundation of
past articles of impeachment against
past presidents indeed these kinds of
abuse of power and obstruction of
justice or obstruction of Congress are
exactly the kinds of things that past
presidents have been impeached on in the
past from my perspective it's
interesting that the house did not pass
a third article of impeachment against
President Trump related to primary
certainly acts of bribery are outlined
in the first article of impeachment
against President Trump so it's
interesting that they didn't go the step
further to actually name a specific
article of impeachment related to
bribery mainly because there's so much
debate about what qualifies as a high
crime or misdemeanor for the purposes of
impeachment but remember bribery is
listed as the things that you can
impeach a president on along with high
crimes or misdemeanors so it's
interesting that the house decided not
to include an explicit article of
impeachment related to bribery itself so
what's going to happen to President
Trump in the coming weeks and months
well President Trump is going to be
impeached by the house that much is
certain
that means that he will now be tried in
the Senate now I'm working on another
video to tackle all
the Senate's procedures during the
coming impeachment trial so stay tuned
for that it's certainly unclear whether
any Republicans will vote to remove
President Trump from office but between
the whistleblower complaint the
witnesses that testified in the
impeachment hearings and the articles of
impeachment it's pretty obvious that
this is not going to be particularly
good for president Trump even if he
claims now that it was totally okay and
perfect but it's early in the game and
we still need far far more facts than we
currently have so when you hear the news
reports about the potential impeachment
of President Trump keep in mind that
there is no constitutionally mandated
timeline for impeachment it can take
years but also keep in mind that the
House of Representatives doesn't
actually have to call witnesses or start
an inquiry they could vote to impeach
right away if they wanted to and let the
Senate handle the trial so we will have
to stay tuned now whatever is in the
whistleblower complaint it's pretty
obvious that it's not going to be good
for President Trump even if he now
claims that it was totally okay now
maybe the president can convince his
base that this is nothing but it will
take some really creative spinning of
the truth to get there so if you're
watching mr. president I recommend you
check out creative nonfiction truth with
style by Susan Orlean on Skillshare
Susan is a best-selling author and
longtime New Yorker staff writer and she
walks us through her writing process for
transforming ordinary subjects into
exceptional stories like turning a
simple phone call with a Ukrainian
president into an exceptional story that
leads to the fourth impeachment in US
history Skillshare is an online learning
community that has thousands of classes
on everything like music design
technology and business legal eagles
will get to three months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below plus it
really helps out this channel and it's
great for deflecting political witch
hunts the free premium membership gives
you unlimited access to must know topic
so you can improve your skills and learn
new things all free for two months get
skills share and improve yourself now so
you can get a head start on defending
your perfect call just click on the link
in the description do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out my other real law
reviews over here where I'll see you in
court